what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I've had this question proposed
before because normally we would cover a
DC video today but this is more
interesting so I've had this question
proposed before because we did the video
Red Lantern Hulk what if the Incredible
Hulk got a Red Lantern ring but the
question that people have asked is but
what if Wolverine got a Red Lantern ring
and it's such a cool idea my flows you
guys who don't know in in the Green
Lantern mythos you have the red lanterns
would you're basically governed by rage
kind of a hallmark is that when a Red
Lantern ring is bonded to a person it
replaces their blood with this sort of
like red you know acidic plasma a kind
of kind of substance and the result is
that they go forward as just like these
mindless killing machines you can be
cleansed by like a blue lantern but for
the most part until then you're just
sort of like a mindless beast with
Wolverine it would be a little bit
different I think now it like the outset
right the gut reaction would be wolf
Wolverine became a Red Lantern by
whatever man and whatever means he would
just go on like a blood fueled rage and
just attack everybody with his claws but
here's a problem with that if if that
were to happen and Wolverine were to
just snap lose it and just sort
attacking people somebody would
neutralize them pretty fast I'd bet all
the money in my pockets all the money in
your pockets it would probably be dead
pool because Deadpool knows exactly how
Wolverines healing factor works because
Deadpool's healing factor is modeled on
Wolverines healing factor and so most
everybody like especially Cyclops of the
x-men they know about like the Muramasa
blade which can be used to basically you
know cut Wolverine and then shut down
his healing factor
there's carbonadium which can slow his
healing factor I mean there's a lot of
different things that they can do to
neutralize them and so because of that
because you're not talking about the
Incredible Hulk where you just have like
unlimited raw strength they can just
keep you know amplifying over and over
and over again to the point where he
just becomes this unstoppable
indestructible beast I would actually
switch things up and I would say
Wolverine would not go on like a blood
fueled killing spree he would still kill
the Marvel Universe but he would do it
using guile and stealth so Wolverine as
a character has well really um he's been
an agent of shield he's been part of
multiple intelligence groups on Team X
he was part of that that black ops wet
work team before he was before he was
rolled into the weapons Plus program
he's been an Avenger he's an x-man he's
he's played like all these roles he's
been like basically in and out of every
single superhero team that exists in
Marvel Comics and so he essentially has
like the info he has the ticket of every
single superhero and he knows how to
take every single one of them
and so from there like like the question
becomes how do you stop Wolverine from
becoming like a mindless monster in
truth I would invoke his healing factor
like I would say Wolverines healing
factor is this right like will you
become a red lantern your heart gets
replaced and and that's the end of that
but with Wolverine because he has a
healing factor I would say in this
instance what would end up happening is
the Red Lantern ring would bond to
himself right like something would
happen Wolverine would freak out
whatever is you Wolverine you have great
rage in your heart welcome to the Red
Lantern Corps
so Wolverine gets a Red Lantern ring and
then what you would see is this scenario
where he just kind of goes like
ballistic for a moment in time for maybe
like like two minutes three minutes four
minutes whatever it is and then his
healing factor would take over and his
healing factor would basically like push
out all that red plasma blood stuff it
would essentially purify himself it
would regrow his heart and then it would
just be Wolverine with a Red Lantern
link now the cool thing is that from
there it would break out in like
constructs and things like that it would
allow him to like use a Red Lantern ring
to create all these Red Lantern heart
like constructs now in reality outside
of like the rage and all that kind of
stuff if with regards to the ability to
make hard light constructs there's
really no difference between the Red
Lanterns and the and any of the other
Lantern course they can all make hard
light constructs it's just red lantern
constructs show up as red but it's
basically Wolverine with a Red Lantern
ring now on the surface it doesn't seem
interesting it doesn't seem like that
great but imagine what he could do with
that
like imagine the the holy hell that he
could unleash in reality like again I
think he would do as stealthy and guiley
so the first thing to do would be to
take out like small groups groups that
nobody would really notice they take out
like these these small little villains
here and there and nobody would really
notice that they were gone at least not
at first I mean after a while because
they're villains to various superheroes
superheroes would wonder where they went
to it would be like okay we got to start
taking out people who are a little bit
higher on the totem pole small groups
per se like superhero groups so the
Inhumans Wolverine would take out the
Inhumans first because in reality the
humans are largely cut off like they're
isolated from everyone by the time
people figured out the Inhumans were
dead nobody would really have any reason
to question it from there like it would
go into okay who does he end up taking
out next now this is where the caveat
the the big issues begin to come into
play because then you start running into
things like the x-men the problem with
the x-men is there such a large group
they're so huge in size that what you
end up having is at some point like
almost immediately people would begin to
notice that the x-men are dying and
that's what I think will rain will
basically start using like trickery and
deception in order to pull off this when
so because he's creating hardlight
constructs the question
have to ask here is Ken Wolverine make
heart light constructs and send them
after people without him actually being
there like what Larfleeze does for
example are fleas creates orange light
constructs and then those orange light
constructs can essentially kind of think
for themselves they're basically
autonomous but they're composed of the
spirits of people that he's killed we
could kind of invoke that to a degree
but I would say Wolverine may have to be
there for a short amount of time and so
what you would do is you would have him
show up and basically send the superhero
community into disarray and so he would
show up to like the Xavier Institute and
kill everybody who's there and then
vanish and so people would just be like
what in the world's going on like you
know literally all the x-men or dad but
Wolverines not seen anywhere now from
that point people would start to wonder
well if the xmin are being killed off
then like we have to go through
systematically and figure out who's
surviving and who's not and so you'd
have like the avengers you'd have like
the very super your community's a
Fantastic Four so on and so forth who
would all sort to sort of look around
and say okay you know what's what's
going on here and so Wolverine would
basically have to like play into that
and just say like I have no idea what's
going on but along the way you know he
would say like we should all basically
start looking you know going into our
resources and see if we can't figure out
who it is that's that's doing all this
and so from there it would turn into him
like taking out the Fantastic Four to
play the Fantastic Four gun and it would
literally proceed in that direction
where it's Wolverine just like using a
combination of deception trickery and
manipulation to basically hit the
superhero community into finding out who
this phantom villain is more or less
what is Wolverine the entire time now in
terms of like invoking the hardlight
constructs like those would only be
really used as like a plot device those
are there those are things that pop up
but they wouldn't pop up for very long
because I think that what you would
start to run into is especially with
someone like Reed Richards if they had
like video footage of the hardlight
constructure there was some kind of
evidence of what the hardlight
constructs were then people would ask
what are those and that's when you were
start to get him to read and so on Reed
Richards and iron man and how we blue
Marvel Adam Brashear they were started
to ask questions or like what these
constructs are what they're made of and
they were start to investigate poke
around different things like that now
what this also leads to is is questions
like blue Marvel himself like Adam
Brashear or like this century or The
Incredible Hulk
these powerhouse guys now because
Wolverine is so well-versed in the
Marvel Universe because he's so
well-versed with these various
superheroes we have to believe he would
know how to take them out The Incredible
Hulk is really like unlimited brute
force strength and so I could easily see
it being a scenario where Wolverine just
like grabs like literally in snares and
in a hard like construct and then just
like flies him into space and just like
kind of catapults him into the Sun it
would have to be quick and dirty with
Thor it's a little more
complicated because while for while he
is a powerhouse in and of himself the
idea here is that Thor can technically
he's done it for a brief moment on can't
like survive in space now it can't be
done for like a really long amount of
time but it can't be done for like a
short amount of time yeah now that I
think about it I'm gonna say that in
Thor 387 which I'm which I care if it
was written by Tom DeFalco or Walt
Simonson Idleman Roth called my head
regardless and that story there was a
point where Thor ended up in space and I
think there was a point where he was
like I need to breathe but he could like
hold his breath in space I think it
watches and wanes I think it kind of
fluctuates like some writers say he can
breathe in space uh you know some space
others say he can't I think some say he
can hold his breath for a really long
time oh we can kind of split the
difference and just say that like he can
hold his breath for a while uh how long
he can hold his breath for we don't
really know but if we are talking about
like a Red Lantern Wolverine that has
Thor tragedies hardlight constructs
because Thor has Mjolnir he'd probably
be able to break out of him with the
Incredible Hulk is strength have to
probably build up to it but with with
Thor like he's already at bay zero like
he's already got his his hammer and so
he could just kind of start hammering at
the hard light construct until
eventually he breaks out I don't know
exactly how you would take out Thor if
if you were a Red Lantern
if Wolverine were to grab him and take
off all the way out you know it's like
outside the solar system and fly like
the other side of the galaxy and drop
them off Thor could could possibly make
it back it would depend on how far
Wolverine took him out or Wolverine
could fly him out it could like knock
him out using a hard light construct if
he could like take him by surprise like
sucker punch him basically and then fly
out to the far side of like the galaxy
as fast as he possibly could and drop
him off and the idea could possibly be
that Thor would not be able to make it
back to earth in time before he
suffocates but then in that case he
would just call on like Heimdall to use
the Bifrost and then he would show up in
Asgard and then come back to earth and
that would be the end of that it says
quick teleportation system more or less
so I don't know exactly how he would
defeat Thor I mean if we use the old
version for like the 1960s and we said
that if he loses contact with his hammer
for more than 60 seconds so he had that
Donald Blake concept then all I would
take us for like Wolverine to take the
walking stick and like chuck it into
space and then like just kill Donald
Blake I mean that's that's all you would
really that's all it would really take
but I don't know the Thor aspect would
be a little more difficult on this
century I think could be done much the
same way as like the Incredible Hulk the
same thing with blue Marvel um you
literally just kind of like throw them
out there send them floating out there
or throw them in the Sun or any number
of
what could also be done here this is
actually okay so here's a really cool
idea what he could do with Thor the
Incredible Hulk like with the heavy
hitters is if he goes and kills the
Fantastic Four Wolverine it's not the
sharpest tool in the shed but he does
know how to activate a portal so what he
could do is he could activate the portal
to the negative zone and then like okay
yeah then go to the heavy hitters and
just be like hey I think I found the
person who's killing everybody who took
off to the Phantom Zone we have to go or
to the negative zone we have to go find
him and then like when they open the
negative zone portal just like close it
behind him and then just like leave them
stranded in the negative zone there's no
way for him to break out the only way to
get in and out of the negative zone is
to use a portal that would allow your
energies to cross either that or you
could like push them through without
reversing their polarity and they would
disintegrate Deadpool he could throw on
the Sun Deadpool would be done like that
that would be it the x-men I think the
full brunt of the x-men I think would be
the most difficult thing or I guess the
mutant population because even if you're
talking about like the core x-men roster
that's taken out of the Xavier Institute
you are still talking about some pretty
powerful beings who were out there it
would just kind of be Wolverine taking
them out individually like using his
claws like popping his claws than just
kind of slashing at him so on and so
forth and calling in today Captain
America of course would be one of the
first people to go just because Captain
America would be able to kind of like
rally the superhero community together
um I feel like Ironman like the really
smart guys would have to be some of the
first people to go because they'd be
able to use their intelligence to
decipher pretty quickly what all's going
on now what this does is at least shield
now in reality shield can be taken out
pretty easily like it wouldn't be that
difficult to eliminate them because
you're talking about this great big huge
hulking monstrosity of an organization
like an intelligence agency
I mean Captain America did it with the
greatest of ease and secret empire I
mean you just tricked everybody into
believing that he was a good guy and
they made him
they made him head of shield so I mean
it's not the most difficult thing to do
with Wolverine having previously been a
agent of shield he would have privy to
like all their internal files and like
all the information and databases that
they have and then from there like set
focus on shield itself taking out the
director would be step number one
because if no one knows who they're
taking direction from and the entire
system comes crashing down that would
pass the number two so on and so forth
and he would have to systematically
break into shield destroy their systems
or computer systems he would he would
just kind of have to go through and
start killing various people
individually now this leaves Nick Fury
who would probably go hide in a bunker
but in reality if there's really no one
left for Nick Fury to rally then it
really doesn't matter in the first place
just because he's alive doesn't mean he
can actually do anything if there's no
real way for him to stop anything and
then yeah like it would literally just
be Wolverine going through
systematically and just taking out
remember like each group in the
superhero community using like stealth
and you know guile and deception all I
kind of good stuff it would definitely
make a cool story like it would
definitely make a make a cool like what
if story like what if Wolverine became a
Red Lantern and like killed the whole
Marvel community I mean we know that
from like the enemy of the state what if
like where Wolverine kills the Marvel
University we know about that that video
be down in the description by the way
but we know we know he can do it even
with just as claws I mean I don't know
it creates an interesting situation then
the question would become what would
like a lot of the villains do like what
would a lot of the villains do if they
realize what was going on in the old man
Logan's story Mysterio uses powers to
trick Wolverine into thinking that the
various villains of the x-men had
attacked the Xavier Institute
all the while Wolverine was killing the
x-men so I mean it's a little bit
different when you're doing that but
like when Mysterio casts an illusion to
trick wolve reign until like realizing
hey look everything's done you defeated
everybody time for you to give up now
yeah I mean is that what would happen
you know like what the heroes and
villains band together to stop wolf
right I mean that's been be an
incredible story like that would be an
amazing story but anyway guys I figured
out to kind of ramble about this for a
little while thought I'd be a pretty
cool idea let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section if
you are new here too comments explained
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]